yanbu car bonjour
bonjour françois pupponi bonjour bonjour
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
je vous propose pour commencer de parler
sécurité avec des candidats surtout à
droite d'ailleurs qui ont fait leur
grand oral hier devant la police alors
que la sécurité est un enjeu majeur la
présidentielle est ce que c'est la bonne
formule finalement pour faire face aux
attentes des policiers selon vous il ya
de boucard
en tout cas il y avait un débat qui
d'organiser hier par un syndicat de
policiers important il était nécessaire
que les candidats viennent dé badiane à
faire leurs propositions sur un enjeu
majeur de cette campagne présidentielle
les français y tiennent beaucoup et
c'est important notamment valérie
pécresse à y faire des propositions
fortes sur cette question de la sécurité
on va en reparler françois pupponi sur
la forme
c'est classique maintenant de plus en
plus de syndicale d'organismes ou
d'organisations diverses au moment des
élections présidentielles organise des
colloques des des réunions leur congrès
et invite les différents candidats venir
s'exprimer donc je pense que sur la
forme c'est plutôt intéressant cs
multiplient maintenant et est donc on
aura l'occasion durant cette campagne de
constater qu'à plusieurs moments on va
solliciter les candidats pour qu'ils
puissent dire ce qu'il pense de tel ou
tel sujet en tout cas valérie pécresse
elle a assuré un soutien indéfectible 1
lors de son discours aux forces de
l'ordre en voulant donner je la cite des
preuves d'amour elle refusant aussi de
parler de violences policières écoutez
je serai toujours au côté des policiers
présidente de la république jamais je ne
dirai qu'il y à des violences policières
dans la société l'autorité n'est pas un
jour sur deux je serai indéfectiblement
soutien des forces de l'ordre alors une
référence aux propos d'emmanuel
macromedia brut c'était fin décembre
2020 elle a raison valérie pécresse
françois pupponi non mais je crois que
là-dessus il n'y a pas du débat tout le
monde dit qu'effectivement il ne sait
pas quel candidat peut être
éventuellement ripper blanche on
pourrait dire qu'il ne soutient pas de
jours la police qui l'a démontré qu'il
était souvent en conflit avec elle mais
après la question c est y sert le débat
qui errent que récurrent dans l'autre
dans notre pays s'est il y a
malheureusement parfois des dérives
personnelles leopard et bavures mais on
ne doit pas appeler ça des violences du
système policier ça je crois qu'on est
tous d'accord mais il peut y avoir
parfois effectivement des moments où des
policiers un policier ne respectent pas
le code de déontologie et ne met pas en
oeuvre les pratiques qui sont
acceptables et dans ce cas-là ce
policier de tête sanctionné mais il ne
faut en aucun cas et je pense nous
serons tous d'accord remettre en cause
l'institution qui est une institution
républicaine et qui fait un travail
exceptionnel au profit de la sécurité
des français yanbu car on ne parle pas
de violences policières mais plutôt de
mav eurent également pendant
je suis tout à fait d'accord évidemment
que ce qu'a dit valérie pécresse hier
mais aussi avec ce qu'a dit françois
pupponi à l'instant alors ça ne m'étonne
pas de lui puisque c'est le discours
qu'il a toujours tenu sa pas toujours
été aussi clair en fait dans la bouche
du président la république qui un jour
sur deux a pu faire preuve de deux jours
d'un fort soutien des forces de l'ordre
et puis le lendemain dans une interview
sans doute mal maîtrisée d'android qui
parle de ces violences policières qui
laisse entendre qu'ils auraient un
système de violence un peu un peu
structurelles et s'était nettement moins
claires et ce à sa porte ça porte
préjudice à l'institution républicaine
que la police à cheval on va aller
pécresse qui a d'ailleurs fait une
nouvelle fois le lien entre immigration
et délinquance la question de
l'immigration d'ailleurs au coeur d'un
d'une visite hier des manuels macron
valérie pécresse dit vouloir des quotas
migratoires françois pupponi ce lien
immigration délinquance est ce que vous
le faites
personne ne peut nier qu effectivement
un certain nombre de personnes issues de
l'immigration en particulier bien sûr
que destine bascule aurait dit à cause
de notre pays ça vous pouvez alors après
est-ce qu'il faut généraliser comme cet
effet hier par maladresse et ça m'a un
peu gêné de dire qu'effectivement il y
avait un lien direct entre immigration
et délinquance ça on ne peut pas le
faire seul tir direct mais bien entendu
personne ne peut nier qu'un certain
nombre aux deux pas de population vit si
l'immigration ou de l'émigration
clandestine actuellement sont aussi des
vacances à amauri fille de se promener
dans les prisons françaises pour
s'apercevoir que c'est la réalité la
vraie question et je pense que ça va
être le débat de cette élection
présidentielle est en tout cas après
l'élection ce sera le sujet qu'il faut
arrêter c'est comment nous gérons notre
immigration commandes giron en
particulier notre immigration
clandestine et comment vous nous mettons
à terme à cette situation qui est
insupportable pour notre pays est
insupportable pour l'espace européen
c'est un renard tiers vu hier que les
que les candidats qui se sont présentés
devant les policiers ont beaucoup tourné
autour de ce sujet là c'est un sujet qui
préoccupe les français et qui perd
qu'une autre pays comme qui perturbe le
smash up donc il faudra effectivement
trouvé le moyen d'empêcher l'immigration
clandestine ou alors d'assumer et ça
peut être aussi une situation d'assumer
nos obligations comme un moment les
allemands ont fait en dix ans nous
allons accueillir un million de de
population il subira choses dans notre
pays nous allons les accueillir nous
avons géré cette immigration par contre
il faut trouver le moyen d'empêcher des
l'immigration clandestine et lorsque ces
populations sont arrivés le moyen de les
renvoyer dans leur pays ce qui est
beaucoup plus facile à dire qu'à faire
emmanuel macron qui s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé sur ce sujet hier il a dit
vouloir repenser les équilibres de
schengen renforcer la protection de nos
frontières extérieures et rendent plus
efficace notre politique de retour vers
le pays d'origine il ya de bukavu vous
rejoignez un cc objectifs du chef de
l'état
en tout cas je pense qu'il faut pas
qu'il y ait un million d'immigrés en
bleu suppose que au contraire à nos
concitoyens semblent bien calmes qu'on
est aujourd'hui arrivé à un tournant qui
à vouloir traiter la question des
retours effectivement dans le pays
d'origine notamment de ceux qui sont de
ceux qui sont des vacances
qu'aujourd'hui un vrai sujet des
personnes qui sont condamnées à deux
pays qu'on n'arrive pas forcément à
faire repartir effectivement c'est pas
si simple que ça parce que ça nécessite
l'accord des pays des pays d'origine ce
à chaque fois l'objet d'intenses la
danse négociations mais souvent ces pays
font aussi l'objet de subventions
accordées par la france dans le cadre de
l'aide au développement et donc on
devrait pouvoir un bart avoir un
partenariat beaucoup plus stratégique
sur ces questions là en tout cas il va
falloir réagir jeu réagir je consens que
c'est une préoccupation majeure de notre
pays et nous sommes arrivés à saturation
dans la mesure où nous n'arrivons plus
suffisamment intégré ces populations
immigrées qui arrive qui arrive en
france à oria celle qui arrive parce
qu'elles fuient la guerre parce que
aujourd'hui elles sont en danger et si
tu n'existais les acquis apc dans la
france et aussi tous ceux qui arrivent
de manière clandestine qui sont sur le
sol français depuis des années alors
qu'elles ont fait l'objet d' obligation
de quitter le territoire français
qu'elles ne le sont pas donc il faut
être capable
de montrer aussi que la france sait se
faire respecter et s'est fait respecter
sa loi alors sur la question de la
délinquance il ya une priorité pour eric
zemmour pour lui il faut assouplir les
règles de la légitime défense écoutez
j'ai proposé par exemple
la défense excusable qui allège les
conditions de la légitime défense pour
les citoyens et pour les policiers j'ai
proposé aussi la présomption de légitime
défense qui renverse la charge de la
preuve et qui fera qu'un policier n'aura
plus peur de se défendre en pensant
qu'il sera mise en garde à vue françois
pupponi eric zemmour qui avait déjà dit
un donné à l'honnête homme le droit de
riposter aux voyous la légitime défense
cette notion elle est à revoir
aujourd'hui face à des délinquants de
plus en plus armés selon vous françois
pupponi non je crois que les règles
assez clair les policiers comme
l'éditorial dans des conditions qui sont
assez précise de belles initiatives ont
le droit de se défendre lorsqu'ils ont
effectivement injustement attaqué et
alors il ya tout un débat sur est ce que
les institutions judiciaires parfois ne
protège pas assez les policiers
lorsqu'ils font usage de leurs armes
mais on a la chance d'avoir une police
républicaine on a la chance de police
qui respectent un code de déontologie
qui défend la sécurité des français et
qui ne vivent pas manière abusive de
cette manière et de cette possibilité de
se défendre
moi ce qui est un peu choquant dans les
propos d'eric zemmour c'est le
globalement il va il veut donner un
droit de tuer un orgue à tuyaux
policiers abattus et aux citoyens et ça
je pense que notre pays ce n'est ce
n'est pas acceptable les policiers
d'ailleurs ne le réclame pas ce que
demande des policiers c'est qu' on
puisse lorsqu'ils sont attaqués
sanctionner lourdement ceux qui s'en
prennent elles donc ça ils ont demandé
une protection en partie de l'assistance
judiciaire mais il considère que les
textes actuels leur permettent de faire
usage de leurs armes lorsque
malheureusement ils doivent en faire
usage et nous avons d'ailleurs assoupli
ses règles il y a quelques mois avec la
situation que nous connaissons le et
dites à haut risque donc là tu il n'y a
pas de revendications de l'institution
policière et je répète mon jeu je
conteste il condamne les propos d'eric
zemmour qui doivent globalement est un
tout simplement de d'essayer de donner
un droit que tu es non seulement
français mais également policier yanbu
car on touche pas à la logique défense
si vous voulez y ait un sujet
aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est que contient de platon à certains
médias en tout cas certains ont tendance
à penser que les policiers sont sont
coupables ce qui n'est pas le cas il
faut beaucoup mieux protéger nos
policiers pour autant les propos d'eric
zemmour ne peuvent pas ne peuvent pas
convenir dans la mesure où finalement il
nous explique qu'on pourrait tirer à
tout-va l'honneur de la police
républicaine c'est d'être capable
d'intervenir c'est capable de faire son
travail allez la voir l'un des tous deux
tués par la police les plus faiblement
et moi je suis tout à fait fiable dans
un pays où la police nationale fait un
travail remarquable
sans tirer sur les concitoyens française
sait c'est l'essence même de la police
après le sujet c'est pour mieux protéger
les policiers c'est dans ce sens que
valérie pécresse propose de rétablir la
peine minimale d'un an de prison ferme
pour les auteurs de violences face aux
dépositaires de l'autorité publique il
faut protéger mieux celles et ceux qui
nous protège aujourd'hui c'est le vrai
sujet parce qu'ils sont agressés dans
certains quartiers dans certaines
manifestations
dans notre pays il faut les protéger le
sang sans avoir alors demandé de tirer à
tout va sur les citoyens français
évidemment vous parlez de la justice
aussi tous les deux la justice au coeur
un des discours des candidats une
volonté affichée par certains de plus de
sévérité dans les peines vous en parlais
à l'instant ou en tout cas dans des
peines appliquées est ce que le problème
de la police françois pupponi c'est la
justice c'est ce que dénonce le syndicat
alliance d'ailleurs si ce que club
allemand les policiers le syndicat et de
citoyens
condamnés ils contestent à juste titre
parce que on est parfois très
interpellé choqué interrogatif devant
certaines peines il ya eu cette semaine
une jeune femme qui malheureusement
après décidé mais d'aider des jeunes qui
ont été condamnés à un an de prison pour
un viol collectif
donc il ya effectivement vous gâte de la
part de la justice soit une nécessité de
changer un peu la mère de fonctionner ou
lorsqu'ils prennent une peine comme
celle-là il a décidé d'expliquer parce
que ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est une
incompréhension totale entre les
citoyens entre les français et leur
justice sur un certain nombre de
décisions à tous des exemples presque
quotidiennement et il est payé et les
policiers les premiers dans les
quartiers où j'habite au 10 mai des fois
qu'est ce que ça à quoi ça sert d'aller
interpeller quelqu'un puisque deux
heures après il est dehors donc
effectivement on a un problème de chaîne
pénale il va falloir changer de
certaines lois j'en suis convaincu mais
surtout la manière dont la justice devra
expliquer justifier ses décisions pour
qu'elle soit plus compréhensible alors
la police la gendarmerie
face à un nombre de suicides
catastrophique en ce début d'année 2022
des chiffres nettement plus haut que
ceux observés naturellement un vrai
signal dallaire d'hôtes donc il ya
urgence selon vous à faire de la
prévention a davantage accompagner plus
ses personnels est ce que on est en
retard finalement à ce niveau-là yanbu
car
oui aux no retard est en réalité cette
augmentation des suds la police allait
elle remonte pas seulement cette année
on voit cette augmentation depuis depuis
depuis quelques temps il ya nécessité
d'un accompagnement social et
psychologique au sein de nos forces de
police en corse dans les armureries pour
mieux suivre pour mieux accompagner les
personnels qui peuvent parfois vivre des
drames qui peuvent parfois mal réagir à
des situations du quotidien as qui le
qu'ils subissent et qu'il prenne qu'ils
prennent très mal aujourd'hui on a un
signal d'alerté avec des chiffres en ce
début d'année qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement inquiétant il ya nécessité
de prendre des mesures oui françois
pupponi vous le disiez vous parlé avec
des policiers de votre commune qu'est ce
qui vous dit ce malaise vous l'expliquez
comment
écouter le malaise dans la police il
remonte depuis plusieurs plusieurs
années nous public collectivement je
pense que les nous n'avons pas été
suffisamment à côté des policiers en
termes de locaux en termes de moyens
pour qu'il puisse accueillir et
accomplir leur tâche dans des bonnes
conditions en termes de recrutement en
tain de formation on les a beaucoup
beaucoup sollicités surtout ces
dernières années beaucoup et on les a
pas suffisamment accompagner
suffisamment écouté ça ils le disent
tous pour les rencontrer régulièrement
ils travaillent dans des conditions qui
ne sont plus des conditions acceptables
une fois qu'on a dit ça bien la bonne
avant la privation conscience très vite
mais quand on dit qu'il faut rénover les
commissariats conseiller cela est bien
ça prend plusieurs années quand on dit
qu'il faut recruter s'apprend pas encore
plusieurs années le matériel ça a l'air
d'aller un peu mieux mais ce n'est pas
suffisant donc il faut effectivement que
les policiers soient au moins dans des
conditions de fonctionnement des centres
normal il ya des commissariats compte ce
n'est pas le cas je vois le commissariat
de sarcelles ce n'est pas le cas ils
travaillent dans des conditions qui ne
sont pas acceptables
la décision a été prise de confiance au
commissariat mais ce n'est pas encore
fait et loin de là donc voilà il faut la
continuer après ils sont comme tout le
monde avec des problèmes personnels et
donc le mélange des conditions de
travail sont pas acceptables et le prêt
personnel s'est correctement aux
m'arrive une situation qui est
insupportable en termes de taux de
suicide il va falloir vite réagir mais
je le répète la difficulté c'est
qu'entre le moment de la réaction et au
moment où les policiers verront sur le
terrain qu effectivement les conditions
changent il pourra 10 passant encore
beaucoup de temps et c'est là où la
difficulté avant de passer à un autre
sujet l'invitation à des policiers
déclinée par un par la gauche vous le
comprenez comment tient debout car
la police votent à droite
peu importe si la police est à droite
puisque aujourd'hui la police est une
association républicaine la sécurité est
un enjeu national moi je regrette je
regrette que certains n'aient pas voulu
participer à ce débat pour des raisons
politiques puisque en l'occurrence et
certains candidats ont d'abord ya jean
luc mélenchon qui n'a jamais été en
soutien de la police bien au contraire
je comprends qu'il ait pas été qui est
pas un invité
il ya d'autres candidats de gauche qui
ont sans doute qu'ils ne s'en doute pas
voulu participer
pour faire pour faire des gages à
certains à certains militants etc et
c'est bien dommage ce qui aura des
propositions à formuler j'espère pour
ces candidats là et pour qu'ils aient
des bisons d'un conte ventes à sociétés
qui se confrontent à l'occasion de
l'élection présidentielle la gauche en
tout cas présentent à la fondation abbé
pierre sur le mal-logement la fondation
qui dénonce d'ailleurs un le bilan des
manuels macron sur le logement le
gouvernement qui reconnaît des erreurs
regardez
c'est une mesure qui avait été apportée
par bercy qui est une mesure de
techniciens si on devait la reprendre on
ne la reprendrais pas aujourd'hui
françois pupponi sur le mal logement
vous le reconnaissez le gouvernement n'a
pas été à la hauteur
sur le mal logement sur le logement ou
tout simplement oui mais on l'a dit hier
l'erreur de départ de la baisse de l'apl
qui a coûté quand même quelques
milliards d'euros aux bailleurs sociaux
et qui a plombé un peu les comptes et
était une erreur
aussi
psychologique parce que c'était le
message que le logement ça coûte de
l'argent alors bon de logements ça ne
coûte pas d'argent ça rapporte de
l'argent d'âge d'ailleurs au budget de
l'état et surtout le beau joueur le
logement et la politique du logement
c'est indispensable pour que les
français puissent trouver un logement
digne quel que soit l'endroit du
territoire il sait tout alors donc
effectivement cette erreur des apl pas
aimer les vins qu'on l'a reconnu c'est
moi je suis un peu spécialiste du
logement ça fait 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans
que bercy chaque fois qu'elle nous
ministre du logement arrive avec la
proposition de dire on va baisser d
appel donc on va économiser car sur les
40 milliards d'euros mais ça coûtera
moins à l'état l'a effectivement au
début de la mandature
le choix était fait d'accepter ce
problème c'était une erreur et ait
reconnu maintenant depuis maintenant
deux ans une politique de relance du
logement est engagé il va falloir
continuer on ne peut pas continuer notre
pays à avoir des gens qu'ils soient
soient pas logés du tout cuit dans la
rue soit très mal logés et en tout cas y
manque on le sait avec environ 80 90
mille logements de plus par an à
construire pour régler ce problème ça
coûtera de l'argent ça nécessitera des
investissements mais il est
indispensable de le faire on voit bien
que le logement est devenu une des
principales préoccupations des français
yanbu car une priorité également pour
valérie pécresse cette cette question du
logement
sévit damon priorité dans la mesure où
ces préoccupations de nos concitoyens
c'est aujourd'hui le 1er poste de
dépenses de chaque ménage et c'est bien
normal pour réagir à ce qui est dit
cheikh le point ce n'est pas que la
politique du logement devenu macro était
mauvaise et qu'il n'a pas lu ont été vus
cette bd appel en début de mandat qui a
gravement handicapé les capacités
d'investissement et d'aller habilitation
des bailleurs sociaux et puis après plus
rien on nous annonce est un choc de
l'offre qui dès qu'ils n'aient jamais
qu'il est jamais venu on a vu
l'exclusion à venir dans les quelques
blancs quelques mois des logements qui
n'auraient pas les bottes l'étiquette
énergétique sans accompagner les
bailleurs qui sont pas forcément des
bayous et les meilleurs voyous qui
veulent pas réhabiliter on a aussi dans
notre pays et c'est le cas chez mon
apple forme je sais que c'est le cas
chez mon collègue à sarcelles des débuts
et des bailleurs qui n'ont pas les
moyens de réhabiliter donc ils ont des
logements qui sont moins pas
suffisamment convenable il faut les
accompagner il faut mettre de l'argent
sur la table parce que ces logements
l'inde a besoin aujourd'hui à des
français qui ne sont pas logés du tout
des français qui sont mal logées
effectivement c'est une politique qui
coûtent évidemment de l'argent mais
c'est aussi une politique qui rapporte
parce que ça fait travailler des
entreprises françaises pour construire
pour réhabiliter et puis c'est une
nécessité dans un pays développé comme
le nôtre d'avoir des logements adaptés à
la population il nous reste 5 minutes
dans l'actualité également la situation
sanitaire et cette déclaration d'olivier
ferrand hier soir sur la fin du pass
vaccinale probablement avant le mois de
juillet prochain françois pupponi il
était temps
non ça a été toujours très claire dans
toutes les discussions qu'on a eues au
parlement le mouvement a toujours
annoncé qu'il demandait l'autorisation
de pouvoir le maintenir au moins
jusqu'en juillet en expliquant à chaque
fois que bien entendu que si la
situation sanitaire s'améliorait il n'y
aura aucune raison de le maintenir donc
là les choses sont en train on est loin
d'être sortis de cette crise sanitaire
mais on voit bien que petit à petit on
est peut-être peut-être en train de
sortir cette piste et que ce qu'a dit le
ministre hier c'est que les six
effectivement la situation continue à
s'améliorer faisons encore au coeur de
la crise si elle continue à s'améliorer
il est rare aucune raison de maintenir
ce pas salutaire donc ça ç'a toujours
été dit par le gouvernement il y avait
une date limite était juillet mais avec
la possibilité de mettre un terme à ce
passe avant si effectivement les choses
allaient dans le bon sens yann
contre-réaction pardon tient debout car
sur cette annonce
c'est c'est logique évidemment c'est
logique évidemment que si la situation
sanitaire le permettent on enlève cette
passe anitea lequel est petit à petit
toutes les restrictions qui peuvent
s'appliquer dans le bi quotidienne c'est
l'enjeu c'est l'enjeu du pass vaccinale
d'abord ça te dire que il faut qu'on
avance sur le sur la crise sanitaire qui
doit retrouver une vie normale le
deuxième enjeu c'est que les français
aujourd'hui font preuve d'énormément de
responsabilités font respecter gspr hier
les entreprises se sont adaptées au
télétravail l'enjeu c'est que ça aille
mieux pour qu'on puisse vite retrouver
une vie normale alors la question de la
vaccination avec la troisième dose qui
suscite encore le débat voyez ce qu'en
pense la dig morano
qu'on réserve la vaccination aux
personnes fragiles moi je ne ferai pas
de troisième dose le problème c'est
qu'on peut plus rien faire on peut plus
circuler ni travailler déjà au départ je
ne voulais même pas faire la deuxième
dose mais je ne pouvais plus rentrer au
parlement européen vous rendez compte
une vaccination administrative dénoncé
par un nadine morano françois pupponi
elle a raison écouter essayer d'écouter
les spécialistes les spécialistes de la
santé qui nous disent qu effectivement
aujourd'hui si on va avoir une meilleure
protection vis-à-vis du virus même si ça
n'empêche pas de contracter la maladie
dans tout cas ça évite les formes graves
il faut des doses
ou avoir été s'était rappelée par le
ministre hier ou avoir été avoir
contacté le virus et le café car moi je
prends mon cas personnel j'ai deux doses
et gilles va attraper une fois le virus
soit là et j'ai mon pass et il ça me
permet en tout cas ce serait le pianiste
est en tout cas j'ai le sentiment de que
ça fonctionne d'être mieux protégés
voilà donc après c'est le choix de
chaque personne est obligée de se
vacciner la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire mais quand on essaie
d'écouter le mot médicales au moins ça
m'a convaincu de dire qu'il fallait
effectivement à la fois faire les doses
pour être mieux protégés après c'est la
liberté de chacun ilian bout car pour le
conclure le mot de la fin
comme chaque année nos concitoyens ma
collègue et amie nadine morano fait fait
comme elle l'entend la vaccination des
publics à tant d'autres pays moi je suis
pas considéré comme personnes à risque
comme personne fragile j'ai contracté le
caue vite gêné de doses la porte bien et
puisque mon médecin me le conseil et que
les médecins et les spécialistes
conseillent si je n'avais pas eu le
comité aurait fait la troisième dose
sans aucun état d'âme merci à vous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france merci anne boucard
députés les républicains de belfort
merci à vous françois pupponi député
modem du val d'oise et